THAT WOULD INFLAME THE DIVIDES.
HE WAS LIKE I CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS.
BUT LET'S TAKE A LOOK NOW AT
ANOTHER PORTION OF THIS
DOCUMENTARY.
IT'S AN INTERVIEW WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
THIS IS AFTER THE INSURRECTION
N. THIS IS IN MARCH OF 2021.
AT HIS FLORIDA HOME, MAR-A-LAGO.
>> CAN WE TALK FOR A MINUTE
ABOUT JANUARY 6TH?
>> YEAH.
WELL, IT WAS A SAD DAY, BUT IT
WAS A DAY WHERE THERE WAS GREAT
ANGER IN OUR COUNTRY.
PEOPLE WENT TO WASHINGTON
PRIMARILY BECAUSE THEY WERE
ANGRY WITH AN ELECTION THAT THEY
THINK WAS RIGGED.
A VERY SMALL PORTION, AS YOU
KNOW, WENT DOWN TO THE CAPITOL,
AND THEN A VERY SMALL PORTION OF
THEM WENT IN.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THEY WERE
ANGRY FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE ELECTION.
BECAUSE THEY'RE SMART, AND THEY
SAY AND THEY SAW WHAT HAPPENED,
AND I BELIEVE THAT THAT WAS A
BIG PART OF WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH.
>> THAT'S ACTUALLY PRETTY
RESTRAINED.
HE'S JUSTIFYING THE CRIMINALITY
AND THE INSURRECTIONISTS.
HE'S DOWN PLAYING WHAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO DO.
THEY WERE NOT JUST EXPRESS
ANGER.
THERE WERE THERE TO STOP GIVING
THE PRESIDENCY.
>> HE WAS TALKING AS IF IT JUST
HAPPENED IN A PLACE FAR AWAY
FROM ANYTHING THAT HE DID OR
SAID OR NOW THAT WE ARE SEEING,
TRIED TO COORDINATE WITH THE
PEOPLE AROUND HIM.
THEY DIDN'T JUST GET ANGRY.
HE MADE THEM ANGRY BY TELLING
THEM LIES.
AND HE'S NOT SEPARATED FROM
THAT.
EVEN THOUGH HE'S TRYING TO
SEPARATE HIMSELF.
THAT IS CLASSIC DONALD TRUMP.
HE KNOWS BECAUSE HE DID THIS HIS
ENTIRE LIFE, IF YOU SAY
SOMETHING ENOUGH TIMES, AND IF
YOU SELL WHATEVER YOU'RE TRYING
TO SELL, WHETHER IT'S AN IDEA OR
A PRODUCT, ENOUGH TIMES THE SAME
WAY, YOU CAN GET PEOPLE TO SIGN
ON.
>> LET'S BE HONEST.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS THAT THERE WAS
NOT ONE WORD OF CONDEMNATION
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH THAT CAME OUT OF HIS
MOUTH AT THAT TIME.
BUT IT'S ALSO NOTABLE THAT THAT
POSITION THAT TRUMP HAD THEN IN
THE MONTHS AFTER JANUARY 6TH IS
ACTUALLY THE POSITION THAT HAS
BEEN ADOPTED BY MANY REPUBLICANS
TODAY.
MANY LAWMAKERS ON CAPITOL HILL,
WHICH IS TO SAY OH, IT WAS JUST
A FEW PEOPLE.
IGNORING TOTALLY THE VIOLENCE
AND THE INTENT HERE WHICH WAS TO
STOP THE PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER.
THIS IS A PORTRAIT OF A FORMER
PRESIDENT WHO IS STILL
CULTIVATING WHAT HE DESCRIBED AS
ANGER ON THAT DAY.
AND THAT, I THINK, IS WHAT THE
COMMITTEE AS WE'RE GOING THROUGH
THE HEARINGS, WANTS TO REITERATE
TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
IT'S WHAT JUDGE LUTTIG SAID.
THE CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER FOR
THE FUTURE, A FORMER PRESIDENT
WHO IS NOT REMORSEFUL BUT IS
ALSO STILL STIRRING UP THE ANGER
THAT MIGHT REAPAIR AT SOME
POINT.
>> TO ON BY'S POINT, NOT ONLY
DOESN'T HE CONDEMN.
HE CALLS THEM SMART AFTER ALL OF
THIS.
THERE IS NO MENTION OF THE
PEOPLE WHO DIED.
THERE IS NO MENTION OF ALL OF
THE POLICE OFFICERS WHO WERE
INJURED.
THERE IS NO MENTION OF THE
DESTRUCTION, THE THREATS, HANG